now for every member of the mob asking
uh and saying how dare Hannity ask these
questions do you even know what my job
is you don't even know what your own job
is I a member of the press whether you
like it or not I am a talk show host on
radio and TV I can produce thousands of
hours of Television radio coverage that
is straight cover straight news coverage
we also do investigative reporting you
know we got the Russia hoax right you
all got it wrong uh we're investigating
the Biden family Syndicate you're not we
got Obama's radical association's right
we talk about sports we talk about pop
culture I give my opinion I'm honest
about it and I'm kind of like an entire
newspaper that's my job is to ask these
questions so I can accurately report
back to my listeners to my viewers what
is happening here with the reaction to
this plus how Israel should respond to
Hamas their heinous attacks former
Speaker of the House new gingr is with
us amazing that you know I am admitting
that I am a talk show host and I have
varying roles they claim they're
journalists they're not journalists are
they Mr
Speaker well they're propagandist for
the left but I me listening to you
defend yourself that was pretty good I
mean you had that down path I uh I
always like it when you start getting on
a roll you got attacked a lot right so
that's good stuff yeah over the years
you know I think there's one thing
people need to know about Jim Jordan uh
in his wrestling career he was 156 to1
he won two national
championships and if you know
competitive wrestlers they're very
focused they're very determined uh they
have an enormous Instinct for figuring
out how to get the other person to lose
uh and Jordan is a very serious very
competent person CL and I were able to
have dinner with he and his team just
before this Congress opened up and it
was very revealing watching him work
with the entire committee and how close
he was to his committee members my guess
is either on the first or the second
ballot tomorrow he will be the speaker I
think uh speaker McCarthy has a pretty
good sense of exactly where they are he
has a good chance of making in the first
ballot I think he almost certainly will
make it on the second ballot because
there there are a handful of of
moderates frankly who are so angry at
the Benedict Arnolds who created this
mess that I think they find it hard to
turn right around and give them a chance
to say GI I won look look how smart I am
so several of them have indicated they
might vote for for example for speaker
McCarthy on the first ballot my hunch is
if they did they would pivot and
immediately a vote for Jim Jordan I
suspect except for the couple of people
who are nuts on the and so we're part of
that eight people who betrayed their
party I suspect almost every Republican
now understands that with a war going on
in Israel with a war going on in Ukraine
with the problems we have on the border
this is not a time for the house
Republican party to look childish and
silly and IND disarray and I think the
pressure will be very great tomorrow to
elect Jordan and I think Jordan will be
a very strong very compelling speaker
and I think he will be a very represent
the whole party I think in that sense he
he gets it he certainly has as as the a
Judiciary Committee chairman uh and I
think he will be very smart at getting
things done and of course he's got the
same deadlines McCarthy had and I do
think frankly having the government
still open with the war going on Israel
vindicates McCarthy's judgment uh and
that he did the right thing for the
country even if it made eight people
angry at him in the conference whether
you like him or don't like him you got
to admit he's being pretty gracious in
in helping to to reopen the people's
house which I would argue is it has to
happen it is an imperative uh especially
with all that you mentioned going on
let's get your take on Israel to me the
outcome needs to be and I think it will
be Israel wins even if they're fighting
a two-front war in the North Lebanon
Hezbollah in the South Gaza Hamas all
funded by Iran uh so they got very
difficult military challenges ahead of
them uh and I think America our house
needs to be open however the question is
I think the outcome has to be not only
winning but Gaza has has got they've got
to end Gaza as a launching pad for the
tens and tens of thousands of rockets
over the years they are fired into
neighboring very very close by uh
Israeli cities that has to come to an
end once and for all and I'm not sure
Biden has the stomach to allow them to
do what they need to do to protect
themselves your
thoughts well President Biden going to
Jerusalem frankly worries me because I
don't think we have any idea what he's
likely to do and given how weak and how
appeasement oriented towards Iran that
his administration has been uh it has me
worried look there are three things and
and a good friend of mine Heather
Higgins wrote me about this this evening
there are three things that uh Biden
could do immediately one he could seize
the billions of dollars sitting in
gutter that should never ever go to Iran
they still haven't done that it's
utterly inexplicable two uh he could
pressure Egypt and others to a for a
temporary agreement to get people out of
Gaza uh it's very important if you want
to minimize civilian casualties to find
a way for them to get out of the way of
what should be uh and which I totally
support a thoroughly crushing Israeli
ground offensive uh designed to destroy
and eliminate Hamas I mean if if if
Hamas exists a year from now they have
won this has been a victory for them if
Hamas is truly destroyed it'll send a
signal to Hezbollah in the north it'll
send a signal to Iran that you're going
to mess with us at your own risk the
third thing I think Biden has to do is
communicate to Iran and to Hezbollah
that we will hold them accountable and
by that I mean you don't send two
nuclear aircraft carriers and their
battle groups to the Eastern
Mediterranean as a PR event we have to
be prepared to take out every asset
Hezbollah has if they decide to open a
second front against Israel uh we have
the capacity to do it uh one one bar
battle group alone has over 800 tomahawk
missiles uh and I think that we need to
communicate clearly you get into this
game you're going to be crushed
decisively and you're going to follow
Hamas into the into the uh trash bin of
History all right Mr Speaker new king
Rich always good to have you sir thank
you for being with us hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else